the reason the course that you bought
didn't make you money is
oftentimes because the thing that the
course taught is not the only thing that
is required to make money i bought a
course on copywriting or i bought a
course on facebook ads and i didn't make
money it's not because the course was
bad maybe it was it's probably because
you're missing another piece of the
puzzle and that's why it takes so long
for so many people when they get into
the game and they get so frustrated at
the beginning because everybody tells
the story i bought all these courses
didn't work for me and then i finally
got this thing and then it all took off
but many times that last course was just
the last piece of a bridge that other
people helped you build it's much more
important to see it as a bridge from
where you are and where you're trying to
go and each one of the bricks represents
the skill that you'll need if you do not
have one of the bricks you will not be
able to continue to pass the difficulty
in what most people have is that they
continue to reinforce one brick and they
still have a gap spot the gap in your
learning and then attack it ruthlessly